[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60 18 26 minutes pour
faire le tour d'horizon de l'actualité
locale
tout de suite les titres et de ce mardi
20 février une rencontre avec deux
jeunes palestiniens il était présent
hier pour une conférence à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines est
les participants ont pu plonger dans le
quotidien de la villa d'hébron afin de
mieux comprendre le contexte et les
enjeux en palestine reportage à suivre
et des mesures choc pour une réforme
profonde du système ferroviaire français
le rapport aux spinetta remis au premier
ministre d'albret sein diagnostiqué
formule 43 propositions certaines sont
radicales notamment la fin du statut de
cheminot al embauche à la sncf elle nous
en parlons avec axel personnes
secrétaire général de la cgt cheminots
trappe
enfin que disent les chats quand on leur
pose les bonnes questions interrogations
formulées par valli blinoise flore de
claire dans son ouvrage paru au courrier
du livre alliés abordent lé thème de la
communication animale et de ses
bénéfices flore de clercq est notre
invité on débute donc ce journal par
cette conférence organisée hier soir à
lui vs qu elle avait pour thématique
hébron elle les jeunes et la
colonisation deux jeunes palestiniens et
étaient présents pour cette rencontre
retour sur cette soirée avec nicolas
kirilow liszt
la soirée a débuté sur une mise en scène
c'est un contrôle d'identité sans raison
apparente
mourad s'est glissé pour cette fois dans
la peau d'un militaire israélien pour
mieux décrire son quotidien et celui de
chérine deux jeunes habitants d'hébron
en palestine - corps en tant que cameron
it
je suis jamais été dans la rue
principale de ma vie donc c'était fermé
avant que je sois né l'impossibilité de
se déplacer dont la vieille ville les
discriminations subies ou encore la peur
de marcher dans les rues le soir ces
deux jeunes palestiniens ont témoigné
directement sans intermédiaire
l'objectif affiché par la conférence ça
permet à chacun de se faire sa propre
idée au delà de ce que l'on peut penser
de ce qu'on peut entendre sur la
situation et de conflits au moyen-orient
et donc chacun peut voir directement
poser ces questions on voulait
simplement avoir un témoignage sans
avoir une influence derrière d'intérêt à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines était la première étape
d'une série de conférences organisées
partout en france jusqu'au 1er mars
des conférences pour en savoir un peu
plus sur la vie des plus jeunes piégé
dans l'un des conflits les plus vieux du
monde visite présidentielle aujourd'hui
dans les yvelines emmanuel macron s'est
rendu à la médiathèque des mureaux qui a
la particularité d'être ouverte
également tous les dimanches un
déplacement compagnie de la ministre de
la culture françoise nyssen et de
l'académicien erik orsenna le chef de
l'état veut impulser l extension des
horaires d'ouverture des bibliothèques
en débloquant des fonds pour aider les
collectivités l'une des promesses de
campagne l'objectif est de favoriser
l'accès à la culture
le gouvernement qui prépare actuellement
sa future loi sur les mobilités iard a
débuté avec les différents syndicats du
ferroviaire des négociations sur la
réforme du rail c'est dans ce contexte
que l'ancien patron d'air france klm
jean cyril spinetta a remis son rapport
au premier ministre edouard philippe
c'était jeudi dernier
ce rapport de 127 pages se fixe un objet
tif transformer en profondeur un système
ferroviaire français à bout de souffle
quarante trois propositions drastiques
sont proposés l'ouverture à la
concurrence sur le rail notamment
suppression de nombreuses petites lignes
et qui ne sont pas assez rentables et
également la fin du statut de cheminot
al embauche avec moi pour parler de ce
sujet en invité avec celle personnes
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le secrétaire
général de la cgt cheminots trappe fin
du statut de cheminot à lambeau cela
veut dire une fin progressive des
cheminot à la sncf
rappelons que ça représente 90% des
salariés de la sncf aujourd'hui quelle
réaction vous avez eu à la divulguer la
divulgation de ce rapport
la réaction est évidemment une réaction
de l'opposition puisque c'est une
attaque pas que contre les cheminots
c'est une attaque contre les voyageurs
parce que comme vous l'avez précisé dans
votre introduction il est question d'une
fermeture de jusqu'à 9000 km de lignes
ferroviaires c'est à dire presque un
tiers du réseau ferroviaire
en plus de ça dans le rapport spinetta
il est préconisé la fin du tarif maximum
qu'impose l'état en seconde classe
notamment pour les prix des billets tgv
dont il est question donc de pouvoir
augmenter encore plus les billets qui
sont déjà suffisamment cher comme ça
aujourd'hui et enfin évidemment il ya
aussi une attaque contre les conditions
d'existence des cheminots et notamment
celle des générations à venir où il est
préconisé notamment de mettre fin au
statut al embauche pour ceux qui vont
venir après mois les générations de
cheminots suivante donc les trappes de
la section de traque commence a été
reçue également donc ça a été reçue ce
n'est pas une surprise puisque c'est la
continuité des attaques qui ont eu lieu
ces dernières années
ça c'est le parachèvement des réformes
qui ont été entamées ces dix dernières
années mais c'est la réaction qui domine
c'est évidemment une réaction on va une
projection combative on va s'opposer à
ce projet et je tiens à souligner votre
attention sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas
que les cheminots qui dénonce les
préconisations de ce rapport et les
associations de voyageurs notamment ceux
qui sont impactés par les fermetures de
ligne y compris les associations
écologistes qui pointent que ce rapport
s'il venait à être mise en oeuvre
occasionnerait des graves dommages à
l'environnement il ne prend pas en
compte les problèmes de réchauffement
climatique et évidemment il suscite
l'opposition des cheminots qui
défendront comme nous ils ont toujours
fait leurs conditions d'existence de vie
et de travail temps pour eux en bouche
actuellement que pour les générations à
venir
en valais on va avoir l'occasion d'en
parler juste après elisabeth bande qui
avait misé
transport dit que du rapport spinetta
qui le pose un diagnostic sévère mais
malheureusement très juste à votre avis
est ce qu une réforme en profondeur de
la sncf et tel est elle nécessaire on
rappelle que la sncf ces 2,6 1 milliards
d'euros de déficit par an une dette qui
pourrait être reprise tout ou partie par
l'état à sa charge ça c'est prévu dans
cette réforme des mobilités il n'est pas
nécessaire de modifier les choses se
renvoient aussi il ya plein de choses
qu'on pourrait modifier notamment en
matière d'embauché on est en
sous-effectif chronique depuis plusieurs
années les prix sont beaucoup trop
élevés en ce qui concerne notamment le
tgv il ya plein de choses qu'on peut
réformer au chemin de fer on est porteur
d'eau mais derrière la sncf va mal
aujourd'hui
vous dénoncez comptable sur le dos des
cheminots ont des noms ce qu'on tape sur
le dos des cheminots qui ne sont en rien
responsables de l'endettement
mais je tiens à préciser une chose vous
parlez d'endettement c'est différent des
profits les profits que génère la sncf
chaque année ce compte cette année vont
se compter en milliards les qu'on doit
être publié d'ici la fin du mois
ce que je tiens aussi à préciser sur la
question de la dette est très rapidement
la sncf a été créée en 1938 notamment
pour absorber toutes les compagnies
privées de l'époque qui était dans une
situation de faillite et d'endettement
généralisé et ont demandé donc à l'état
de reprendre la dette à leur compte et
ensuite donc de payer la dette à la
place des compagnies privées de l'époque
donc c'est depuis le cas la création
sncf que nous sommes lesté de cette
dette que ensuite l'état après la
décision d'alourdir au gré des
investissements sur les lignes à grande
vitesse sur la construction du réseau
banlieue le rer en ile de france et nous
avons mis en oeuvre les investissements
qu'on nous a demandé
mais nous ne sommes pas responsables des
décisions politiques qui conduisent à
creuser l'endettement ce n'est pas de
notre responsabilité est concrètement
avec cette personne pour qu'on soit
clair la fin du statut de cheminot ça ça
impliquerait quoi céder des avantages
sociaux on revient sur des avantages
sociaux notamment le nombre de jours de
congés sur les ped et également beaucoup
de choses inexactes qui circulent dans
certains médias sur ce qu'est le statut
le statut en fait c'est un document qui
compte douze chapitres ya plein de
choses assez banal dedans je pense par
exemple à ce qu'il régit les sanctions
il ya des choses assez qui coule de
source c'est à dire avant d'être
sanctionné un chat vidéo doit être en
mesure de fournir des explications avant
que la direction ne sanctionne c'est pas
ça qui coule le chemin de fer ce qui
pose problème à nos patrons et au
patronat ferroviaire de manière générale
c'est le fait qu'il est prévu dans le
statut le licenciement uniquement en cas
de faute
c'est à dire que le licenciement décidé
au gré des conjonctures économiques
n'est pas prévue dans les textes c'est
ça qui leur pose problème ce qu'ils
veulent
demain ce sont des cheminots qui peuvent
licencier au gré des réorganisations et
auquel il n'aurait pas proposé des
reclassements des propositions d'emplois
ailleurs
c'est ça qui leur pose problème c'est le
fait de vouloir nous licencier au gré de
leurs décisions économiques et ça
évidemment s'y opposera et on pense
plutôt que c'est un élément du statut
qui est porteur de progrès social et non
seulement va le défendre mais on pense
qu'il aurait vocation à s'étendre à
plusieurs branches
il ya pas de raison que nous ce que
c'est bon nous en bénéficions on veut
que plus de salariés que nous en
bénéficions un rapport préconise
également des évolutions pour les
cheminots qui sont déjà en poste
notamment un transfert vers le privé
queen encore une fois des acquis sociaux
bah c'est bien tout ça de la question le
la question c'est le transfert parce
qu'il n'est pas question pour les
opérateurs privés de construire des
nouvelles voies de venir avec de
nouvelles rames et de venir avec de
nouveaux salariés personne n'a cet
argent à disposition ce que les
opérateurs et les industriels du
transport veulent c'est récupérer le
réseau d existence et récupérer les
salariés déjà existants c'est récupéré
le matin déjà existants gratuitement et
évidemment les salariés avec des
conditions de sociales les plus
rabaisser que possible de manière à
dégager le plus de profit que possible
donc c'est finalement une situation de
lutte économique assez classique et en
compte défendre notre intérêt on en a
pas on ne va pas ça ne va pas s'en
excuser et j'encourage tous les salariés
qui subissent cette situation de
l'entreprise à faire de même pas ce
qu'il y'a pas que les cheminots qui sont
exposés à ces attaques
il serait grand temps qu'on se bagarre
tous ensemble dernier point que je
voulais aborder avec vous avec cette
personne sait aussi que le rapport
recommande un plan de départs
volontaires aujourd'hui la sncf contre
150 mille salariés c'est 5000 de trop
selon le rapport de jean cyril spinetta
5000 de trop pour quelle est cette fois
compétitive si on constate la baisse
d'effectifs au chemin de fer je vous
rappelle quand même qu'au sortir la
deuxième guerre mondiale il y avait
presque un demi million de cheminots qui
travaillaient au chemin de fer
aujourd'hui on en est fait à peu près à
150 milles mais les voyageurs peuvent le
constater aujourd'hui avec la
désertification des gares où il ya plus
en plus de mal à trouver un agent pour
se renseigner ou les de plus en plus
difficile de trouver un agent bord des
trains qu'aujourd'hui le problème du
chemin de fer notamment avec les
investissements qu'on nous demande de
réaliser dans le réseau tous les travaux
qui a à faire
aujourd'hui on souffre non pas d'un
sureffectif loin de là mais d'un
sous-effectif qu'il faut absolument
régler parce que c'est la solution
aujourd'hui pour les territoires plus
isolés on parle volontiers de moins
utiliser sa voiture est ce que le train
encore son rôle à jouer si bien sûr
notamment dans un essai pour ça que les
associations écologistes nous rejoindre
dans ce combat c'est que dans un
contexte on parle de réchauffement
climatique d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est un peu enfonce une porte
ouverte mais le transport ferroviaire
notamment le transport ferroviaire
électrifiée est un gage de protection de
l'environnement
donc oui là son avenir il a son intérêt
c'est indéniable la question évidemment
qu'elle et les moyens qui sont prêts à y
mettre
dernière chose la cgt appelle à une
grande mobilisation le 22 mars
d'ici là qu'elles sont un objectif c'est
de faire gonfler cette mobilisation
qu'elle prenne de l'importance
donc le 22 mars sur une manifestation
nationale de tous les cheminots du
territoire qui défileront à paris pour
lancer donc la contestation contre le
projet de loi
il y aura des associations d'usagers qui
vont nous rejoindre la manifestation
ainsi que des associations des
écologistes je tiens à le souligner est
peut-être 200 e de syndicats aussi sud
rail unsa ferroviaire attendre encore
avant de dire s'ils se joignent au oui
il est tout à fait possible que le
feront en tout cas strictement syndicale
s'élargit sur cette question et l'enjeu
de la manifestation du 22 mars c'est
évidemment de lancer une contestation
qui ira plus loin s'il le faut si le
gouvernement ne recule pas c'est un
projet évidemment on lancera la question
de la grève et du rapport de force pour
défendre nos intérêts mais aussi ceux du
dieu aussi les intérêts généraux parce
que le diable soulignait les assauts
sont d'usagé à ce sont écologistes qui
nous rejoint dans ce combat c'est donc
un combat d'un virage général challe
grâce à bien sûr sur télé 60 18 mai un
merci à excellent à personne d'avoir été
avec nous secrétaire général de la cgt
cheminots trappe
merci d'avoir été avec nous on continue
de parler à transports jean noël barrot
michel laugier ou encore jean michel
fourgous
ils sont 21 lui d'étiquettes politiques
diverses dont celle de la majorité
présidentielle de la république en
marche et ils ont envoyé un courrier
concernant la ligne 18 à edouard
philippe dans la lettre les co
signataires demandent au premier
ministre de respecter les délais de
livraison du premier tronçon une arrivée
donc en 2024 sur le plateau de saclay
essentiel selon les élus pour le
développement du pôle scientifique
pour rappel les dernières rumeurs sur le
projet font état d'un calendrier retardé
à 2025 voire 2026 pour le premier
tronçon et les arbitrages officiels
n'ont toujours pas été rendus par le
gouvernement votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire à présent le portrait de la
rédaction ce soir c'est un focus croisé
avec quatre membres d'une même famille
ils ont débuté la danse il ya seulement
trois ans et c'est devenu déjà une
passion pour eux la famille participer
ce week-end le week-end dernier à la 2e
édition de la coupe de france sportive
c'est à versailles une rencontre signée
mélanie poker et patrick jacques de
dixmude
tarik birgit tara il ya quatre membres
d'une même famille et le même passion la
danse
une découverte toute nouvelle pour eux
leurs premiers pas de danse sportive
ils les font il ya seulement trois ans
j'ai tout d'abord fait des sports tél
le rugby ou le football je me passais
par le handball
et puis ensuite j'ai décidé de
développer beaucoup plus mon côté
artistique et donc nous voilà et je dois
dire que je préfère dix fois le côté
artistique au côté brut ou au côté très
physique du handball bien sûr la danse
est un sport physique aussi mais dans un
autre sens c'est plus de la
concentration
ce qui me plaît avant tout c'est des
moments qu'on passe ensemble c'est que
c'est vraiment une activité familiale
donc un partage très fort on partage
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de plaisir
beaucoup de passion parfois un peu
d'énervement aussi c'est voilà c'est
mais c'est avant tout un moment un
moment à passer ensemble une passion
devenue dévorante birgit et la président
de leur club
le duo dance club de colombes tarik en
est le vice président ils pratiquent
tous les quatre des danses standards et
latines
[Musique]
nous dans la famille pour l'instant
on aime vraiment les les deux ont donc
on aime les dix danses dans les
standards et latines et pour l'instant
on n'a fait aucun choix
il est probable avec l'âge en général
que les seniors dont l'une ayral à un
moment se concentre plus sur les danses
standards que seuls les danses latines
si tarik et bien qu'ils sont en couple
tard iam son frère et soeur un avantage
pour eux les avantage c'est qu'on peut
se voir tout le temps on a forcément on
est plus familier on avec l'autre plus
ya moins de chaînes de poser les mains
quelque part que si c'était quelqu'un
qu'on connaissait pas bon après on parle
bien sûr aussi des choses bien plus
naturellement parfois des choses
d'exemple
l'un à l'autre parce que forcément se
connaît mieux mais sinon être rsr c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment extraordinaire
ce dimanche il participait à une épreuve
qualificative de coupe de france
tara et liam ont terminé deuxième du
concours de danses standards et vise
l'international
[Musique]
nouvel invité avec moi sur ce plateau
flore de claire bonsoir vous êtes
yvelinoise et vous avez publié chez le
courrier du libre ce livre que disent
les chats quand on leur pose est les
bonnes questions un ouvrage sur la
communication animale au travers de
l'exemple spécifique des chaleurs vous
expliquer comment fonctionne la
communication animale s'est bien fait
aussi les bienfaits qu'elle peut
procurer aussi bien chez l'homme cochon
qu aux animaux déjà première question
sur la démarche pourquoi avoir eu envie
d'écrire un livre sur ce sujet j'ai eu
envie d'écrire un livre sur ce sujet
pour encourager les hommes et les
animaux une nouvelle relation
les animaux ont une conscience a été
établie scientifiquement en 2010 est
très récent les animaux ont dû des
capacités cognitives et meta cognitives
cela signifie qu'ils savent ce qu'ils
font et qu'ils peuvent faire des choix
en plus bien sûr d'avoir des ressenti
des émotions et d'avoir des besoins à
satisfaire et donc j'ai voulu leur
redonner la parole pour qu'il démontre
par eux mêmes leurs multiples capacités
alors vous êtes de formation littéraire
vous est notamment passé par lui fait
est ce que vous avez fait un master à
lui vécu l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui vous travaillez entendre
comme une communicatrice animalière je
vais je vais y arriver
comment s'est opérée ce changement de
carrière comment vous en êtes arrivé à
faire de la communication avec les
animaux alors en fait ça fait plus de
vingt ans que je sais que j'ai des
capacités extrasensorielles et
mais c'était difficile pour moi de les
mettre en application de les
professionnaliser donc j'avais voulu
j'ai voulu avoir un master 2 en
communication et finalement ce sont mes
capacités qui ont pris le dessus et je
me suis installé en tant que thérapeute
et communicatrice animalière alors vous
vous y prenez comment vous pour
communiquer avec les animaux
justement et bien en fait
c'est une affaire assez lointaine
puisque déjà nikola tesla avait établi
qu'il existait des ondes scalaires des
fréquences qui émanait du cosmos à
équité en connexion avec eux tout ce
qu'ils étaient vivants tous les
organismes vivants de notre planète
ensuite il ya un scientifique un
physicien qui s'appelle winfried schuman
qui a établi à 7 83 hertz la fréquence
sur laquelle est connecté tous les êtres
vivants
donc les animaux humains et non humains
et les végétaux et c'est donc sur cette
fréquence que je me connecte d'accord
pour entrer en communication avec
l'animal est dans cet échange je reçois
soit des images soient des mots soient
des sensations soit des émotions et le
chat dans tout ça est ce qu'il a un rôle
particulier par rapport aux autres
animaux plus de plus facile de
communiquer avec un chat pourquoi
choisir le chat pour ce livre parce que
le chat est plus secret il plus
mystérieux parmi l'ensemble des
des animaux de compagnie on a le chien
le cheval le chat essentiellement et
donc il ya beaucoup plus de
d'adoptants qui se tourne vers moi pour
essayer de comprendre de connaître les
motivations de leur animal à se
comporter de telle ou telle façon
alors dans ce livre vous donner la
parole à une cinquantaine de félins on y
apprend notamment que les chats sont
heureux d'être écouté d'ailleurs ça
influe sur leur comportement
le fait qu'ils soient écoutés ou pas
tout à fait le fait d'être écouté leur
redonne en fait une place leur redonne
la fin une reconnaissance de leur
conscience de leur individualité et donc
le fait de les hauts les écouter ils
leur donnent l'occasion de pouvoir
d'être entendu éparses et grâce à cela
ils sont prêts à changer de comportement
ou même à évoluer dans leur mode de
pensée et justement quand ils ne sont
pas écoutés comment le font-ils savoir
par quel type de comportement ne sont
pas gris fait mordre soit à uriner à
côté de la litière soit
signalez violet beaucoup griffer les
murs ou griffer des personnes c'est les
chasses à se faire entendre
on vous en citer aussi dans ce livre sur
le fait qu'elle charroux une relation
particulière avec la mort il ya aussi
cette légende les neuf vies des chats
qui est évoqué dans l'oural oui alors ça
c'est un chapitre plutôt ludique pour
conclure les ouvrages
mais c'est vrai que les chats comme tous
les autres animaux là il ya aucune
différence
ils ont une vraie conscience une
prescience de la mort ils savent la
faire reculer ou la faire avancer la
faire avancer
et il ils ont également une vive
également le deuil comme tous les autres
animaux ça a été prouvé pour les
éléphants les chiens les cacatoès pour
les delphinidés et aux crampes ou
d'autres animaux mais les chats aussi
comme tous les autres animaux est elle
bien fait ça apporte d'avoir une bonne
communication avec son animal a alors
déjà ça facilite les relations l'animal
se sent plus heureux plus entendu donc
il a de moins de comportements agressifs
ou inhabituels ou déplacés moi je sais
que communiquant beaucoup avec macha
thoune
eh bien je lui explique tout je lui jeu
là prévient de tout donc en fait elle se
laisse faire très facilement alors
qu'elle a pas du tout envie d'aller chez
le vétérinaire pour se faire opérer ou
pour d'autres choses
donc ça fallis pardon cela facilite les
relations et pour entre l'homme et
l'animal
et ça apporte surtout à l'homme une
autre vision de
de l'animal de tous les animaux ça lui
permet d'avoir une autre vision plus
écologique plus éthique de l'animal
quels sont les jeunes et les objectifs
derrière je suis en train de perdre ma
voix finalement c'est donner des
conseils pour la communication c'est
aussi d'apporter de la connaissance ou
est sûre sur ce thème de la
communication animalière alors
l'objectif de ce livre c'est de redonner
la parole aux chasses et ce livre est
structuré sous la fin de l'année comme
un guide pratique de la vie quotidienne
du chat donc en fait l'adoptant va
trouver sur différentes thématiques ce
soit la relation à l'adoptant que ce
soit la vie sociale entre chats la santé
l'alimentation les vacances les la
maternité la stérilisation des tas de
chapitres pratique ça va lui donner des
exemples concrets de ce qu'ont pensé de
la réaction d'autres chats qui vont
peut-être l'aider à envisager que son
chat pour être plutôt comme si vous
pourrez penser ils vont envisager ceci
ou cela il a très rapidement où il sera
en dédicace sur le territoire très
prochainement par rapport à ce livre
oui tout à fait alors ce sera tout tout
d'abord
alors sur deux endroits pardon aux pavés
du canal en juin le 9 juin mais
également à l'être voisine
merci à fleur de claire d'avoir est avec
nous je vous un triste rappel vous avez
publié donc chez le courrier du livre ce
livre que 10 lé chat quand on leur pose
les bonnes questions et cet ouvrage pour
plus d'informations sur cet ouvrage
parlons de perdre pardonnez moi vous
pouvez les retrouver sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
le sport avec cette première dans les
yvelines c'est un tournoi de floorball
qui était organisée à buc le week-end
dernier la discipline a dérivé du hockey
est encore confidentiel regroupe une
vingtaine d'adeptes dans le département
un coup de projecteur avec mickaël
millero la folie du flan ball s'est
emparé de buc ce samedi 17 et dimanche
18 février la ville a accueilli le
premier tournoi de cette discipline
organisée dans les yvelines un sport à
porter tout droit des pays scandinaves
c'est comme vieux quai sur glace mais
sans printemps sans la patinoire comme
du hockey sur gazon mais à l'intérieur
donc du coup on est sur l'équivalent
d'un terrain de hand ball donc avec les
mêmes basket avec une crosse et
et on est au chaud ce jour là six
équipes se sont affrontées au gymnase du
prés saint jean dont l'équipe locale des
jets ce de buc
sur le terrain les matchs durent trois
fois vingt minutes avec des pousses de
cinq minutes entre chaque tir tant en
cours ton temps d une part et d'autre du
terrain deux minutes par par shift et
puis ensuite on repart se reposer un
petit peu sur le banc avant de rentrer
il faut pas mal de cardio de rapidité
donc il faut avoir un minimum en fait de
deux conditions sportives et en faisant
du fort beau du coup on la développe
aussi comme pour le hockey sur glace les
équipes sont composées de cinq joueurs
plus un gardien ce dernier reste tout le
match sur le terrain
un poste clé pour remporter la victoire
qu'elle était principal c'est d'avoir
beaucoup de réflexes aussi d'avoir de
l'anticipation pour voir d'où arrive la
balle qu'elle arrive de loin qu'elle
arrive de proches qu'elles arrivent par
un joueur un petit peu décalé c'est le
jeu aussi des adversaires de cette
boucher la vue du gardien et donc faut
vraiment beaucoup de réflexes d arrêt
réflexe des gardiens qui ont conquis le
public de buc et la folie du floorball
n'est pas près de s'arrêter
elle semble même se propager aux
nouvelles générations de la commune
[Musique]
culture avant de refermer ce journal une
exposition originale est organisé
jusqu'au 4 mars à dampierre a baptisé
érotique art
elle regroupe le travail de huit
artistes venus de toute la france c'est
au tour de l'univers de l'érotisme une
exposition sur lequel c'est sur laquelle
s'est penché michael et lui d'euros
attention certaines images qui vont
suivre peuvent heurter la sensibilité
des plus jeunes
[Musique]
les courbes du corps les sentiments
amoureux la sexualité des thématiques
abordées à travers la centaine d'oeuvres
exposées à l'espace grange galerie de
temps pierre un premier événement de ce
type dans la commune l'idée est venue du
fait que j'ai rencontré pas mal
d'artistes qui me disaient qu'ils
n'avaient aucun endroit pour exposer ce
qui était censuré un peu partout sur les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui parce qu'il
ya un retour au puritanisme du baiser
aux situations plus audacieuses
huit artistes venus de toute la france
se dévoile sur un espace d'une centaine
de mètres carrés l'aide du pinceau du
crayon de l'encré de chine
c'est le cas de carreaux 47 ans elle
expose dans cette grange une vingtaine
de francs j'aime bien parler de l'amour
des couples de l'érotisme et pas
seulement de la moi aussi à des dessins
qui parle que d'amour et
souvent autour de la femme ou alors des
coups je sais pas pourquoi les courbes
de la femme je trouve ça joli à dessiner
ou alors les hommes en complément la
masculinité et la féminité qui
s'emboîtent qui se met en valeur malgré
les apparences cette première exposition
de l'année organisée dans la grange n'a
pas pour but de choquer mais de
provoquer la curiosité du public
tous les voisins sont venus ils ont tous
adoré et je pense qu'ils ont tous fait
des enfants pour passer par là
apparemment les gens sont pas si choqué
que ça malgré malgré mes petites
appréhensions été assez étonné la
galerie contient également des peintures
plus évocatrices interdite aux moins de
18 ans pour les découvrir rendez vous
jusqu'au 4 mars tous les dimanches voilà
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
reportages et replay à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]